[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia el final de la guerra en bosnia
cumple 25 años en noviembre de 1995
terminó un desgarrador conflicto en los
balcanes luego de tres años y medio de
haberse desintegrado la antigua
república de yugoslavia yugoslavia cuya
etimología traduce es la voz del sur fue
primero un reino a comienzos del siglo
20 y luego una república federal con el
triunfo de los partisanos en la segunda
guerra mundial como república federal
yugoslavia agrupaba el territorio de
seis naciones actuales eslovenia croacia
bosnia herzegovina serbia montenegro
kosovo y macedonia del norte estamos
hablando de seis identidades nacionales
tres religiones católicos cristianos
ortodoxos y musulmanes dos alfabetos el
latino y el cirílico y cuatro idiomas el
serbocroata el esloveno el macedonio y
el bosnio con la caída del muro de
berlín en 1989 y la disolución de la
unión soviética
en 1991 llegó el final de la amalgama de
comunismo en los balcanes ya no había
una justificación política para que
tantos pueblos y etnias estuvieran
unidos bajo un mismo nombre y partido y
llegó la hora para los proyectos de
estados nacionales soberanos y el camino
de la democracia el primer territorio
que comenzó un proceso independentista
fue el pequeño país de eslovenia convocó
a elecciones pluripartidistas y luego
por cuenta de un referendo declaró su
independencia inmediatamente serbia le
declaró la guerra con el argumento de
mantener la descentralización yugoslava
el caso fue que eslovenia pudo repeler a
las maltrechas tropas yugoslavas en un
período de apenas diez días obteniendo a
su vez un valioso reconocimiento
internacional a eslovenia le seguirían
croacia y bosnia herzegovina como
territorios que buscaron la
independencia y es en este punto en que
comienza una terrible guerra en la cual
murieron más de 100.000 personas
ahora porque pudo eslovenia en 10 días
librarse la ofensiva serbia y en cambio
croacia y bosnia pero sobre todo bosnia
tuvieron más de 3 años de combates la
respuesta es sencilla primero eslovenia
es un país homogéneo habitado por una
mayoría de eslovenos católicos y además
es un territorio rico en cambio bosnia
era el territorio más plurinacional y no
tan rico qué quiere decir esto que
bosnia tenía una población compuesta por
bosnios musulmanes serbios ortodoxos y
croatas católicos todos con pensamientos
e intereses distintos y fue así como los
serbios dentro de bosnia temiendo perder
territorios desataron una guerra que
incluyó el sitio de sarajevo la capital
en los años siguientes la gente de
sarajevo tuvo poca electricidad baja
cobertura de agua y escasez de comida se
trataba de una limpieza étnica de un
odio de los serbios ortodoxos contra los
bosnios musulmanes materializado en
constantes bombardeos y disparos de
francotiradores desde las colinas
alrededor
más de 11.000 residentes de sarajevo
murieron una guerra que enfrentó a
vecinos contra sus propios vecinos e
incluso dividió familias enteras entre
las muchas atrocidades cometidas durante
la guerra se cuenta la masacre de cerca
de 8.000 hombres y niños musulmanes en
srbrenica en julio de 1995 cuando las
tropas serbias comandadas por el general
ratko mat lic invadieron la ciudad que
estaba protegida por cascos azules
holandeses el mundo entero se demoró
mucho en detener este conflicto sólo en
noviembre de 1995 hace 25 años se puso
final a este derramamiento de sangre con
los acuerdos de dayton concebidos en la
base aérea de dayton en ohio eeuu fue el
comienzo para que los líderes políticos
de bosnia serbia y croacia acordaron
separar el país en dos regiones
autónomas una dominada por croatas y
bosnios y otra dominada por los serbios
en el word like this one en bosnia
en una guerra civil como esta en bosnia
no hay ganadores y no podría haber
ganadores todos son perdedores solo la
paz es una victoria
las soluciones logradas aquí incluyen
concesiones dolorosas por todas las
martillo incluso en el concert songs sin
embargo sin tales concesiones sería
imposible tener éxito aquí inserción la
paz sería imposible
stoke city year en virtud de imposible
la corte internacional de justicia
declaró la masacre de srbrenica como un
genocidio en contra del pueblo bosnio
musulmán años después adelantó juicios
marley el líder de las tropas serbias
fue condenado en 2017 a cadena perpetua
por crímenes de guerra incluido el de
aterrorizar a civiles en sarajevo
durante el asedio y el asesinato de las
víctimas de cecebre nitsa el líder
político serbio radovan karadzic fue
encarcelado de por vida y el entonces
presidente serbio slobodan milósevic
murió de un ataque al corazón en una
celda de la prisión de la haya en 2000
y esto mientras esperaba un veredicto
judicial por los cargos que pesaban en
su contra de ser el autor intelectual de
los crímenes de guerra en bosnia gran
parte de las evidencias que tuvo la
corte penal internacional para condenar
a estos líderes serbios fue la
exhumación de miles de bosnios
enterrados por las fuerzas serbias en
fosas comunes un capítulo doloroso para
los balcanes y uno de los últimos
conflictos europeos porque cabe recordar
que tres años después vendría otra
guerra adelantada por los serbios de
kosovo llegamos al final de este
capítulo soy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]